all right uh I've been going on with the
the concept of anatomical positioning so
and this is very important when I don't
choreograph my UK then I have to make
sure that I'm only moving them in a way
uh that is going to benefit my follow-up
movement to whatever movement I first
did okay I can't expect them to get uh
into position for me uh so how I move
them is very very important um uh so
just to review yesterday I I watched the
video from last night it's not exactly
as clear as I was hoping it would be uh
we kind of did it at the tail end of
class uh but in short uh the concept
here is when I stay here with this
footwork and I come around for EO I'm
not in the right place to get his body
into the positioning I'm too far
um
um how do I want to say it if the
technique kind of already passed me and
that's why he comes back to you so when
I step out to the side I start that the
inward spiral right as the shoulder
passes me not when it's already gone
past me so we'll kind of watch the
shoulder
uh would you get grab a Joe real quick
there's one right
there okay so you're going to plot the
vertical plane of his shoulder okay so
when I bring him around this way and I
come over
here okay and here's where his shoulder
is it's way past me that vertical plane
so now when I bring this box this
shoulder has to come back towards me in
order for me to do
it that is all a result of me staying in
place if I move out and this fight now
begins to
rotate you'll see that his shoulder is
not yet past me use my spine as my
vertical plane but as his shoulder gets
to my spinal line that is where the
spiral takes over okay so because you're
in that place time you're in the wrong
place time for the inward spiral to give
you the opening for the EDI ASI okay
that's that's what we were trying to fix
yesterday and that you can do in the um
iito and the
iito is this part right here this part
right here that's it that's the IO but
the iy tyo is not eal that's very
important so as we go
on to take advantage of how small this
window of opportunity is you have to
have your ready okay you can't be
after the fact because if his shoulder
gets way past me the opening is gone so
my other
hand has to be ready to
catch the wrist when his shoulder gets
to my vertical plane so here was the
atmi the atmi is here boom and when I
leave that atmi there I'm going to bring
this hand to this hand as his shoulder
comes to my vertical plane and I catch
it right there catch it
what's happening on your timing aside
from you're already lay and already too
far away because we didn't move our feet
is you're doing the
io and then you're coming here and this
thing is
gone
so this this rule is the yinong grid my
hand on the cross lateral side cannot
take over the responsibilities of the
homolateral side until it reaches the
wui line the middle of my torso so when
I do the atmi it hits on the wui line
the spiral brings his wrist to my other
hand where it can now take over
responsibilities and this can now move
to New responsibilities on the
elbow and all that happens within that
small w window boom it's right there
we'll do it on this
side so I move off protect my zone
Sanctuary I don't think I don't we can
see it okay boom Center Line pass to the
center line and you're
in so get that hand in the EO earlier
but remember I am not doing the fedorite
stuff
where I cross over the wui line and then
pull this over that does not work it's
passing it to the other half and the
Escape goes right into the
elbow you have to remember that don't
peel it off that doesn't work that's
one
two
in depending on your
UK and depending on their
energy you may need one more Loop of the
hand to escape the grip so that you're
not pulling this off Okay so we've done
video on this but I didn't see you doing
it and it's it's so
subtle a lot of times early on my Das
couldn't tell I was even doing it okay
so we're just going to look at this hand
as if it's the I Ty so I go here boom
and I can't get to that elbow from this
angle so stay there please as best you
can Virginia come help
help just balance him okay so if I go
through I'm going to hit his head but
his elbow's back here so I do one more
loop around and that's where the ADI
pushes to the
elbows and usually you have to do that
if your UK like keeps their flow on
grip um you got to disarm the grip
without breaking the rules of
contestation and you have to hit the
elbow because the Keyon tells you to hit
the elbow and you can't pull this hand
ACR AC cross the rot G line so that the
elbow gets catches up where this was
going to hit the head and none of that
flies Okay so uh I'm coming
around this one I got all the way he's
taking the r KY which is a
counter I'm not going to show it but uh
keep your grip this time okay so one two
H I got to do one more little grip one
more little spiral
one
more now all that
said I
cannot um no and maybe you
can't if you're pinning
yourself then you will have to always
wait for for his mask to get off of
you and then it's too late you this
whole thing is the same thing as the
compression without being pinned the
same thing the same I'm not being pinned
so I still am ground V where I can walk
without being pinned okay um and that's
in EO so I do have stents like 10 right
and then he's too far ahead of me I
can't get the
Emi you have to be able to absorb his
energy so he doesn't move away from me
until I can attack the body okay and
that's where we're going to stop at that
EO tesak not the isoiso
tesak and then make mention that you
have to be able as we were talking last
video compress so that you're not pinned
you you have to be able to internalize
young aspect not externally combat it CU
it will pin you you can't move or you
can't move without moving that that's
not the technique you want this opening